Road
hey guys now you've probably already
heard about this new movement called No
poo movement that just sounds strange no
poo what is this well they talking about
shampoo not not poo you know
and they basically believe that you
don't need to wash your hair not in a
week not in a month not in a year never
for example Johnny Harris made a video
where he stopped washing his hair for
five years and here's the Shocker it
still looks good he just rinses it with
water that's how he washes his hair no
shampoo so this no poo movement the
belief basically comes down to this
shampoo is just a money making scheme
where people think they need it but they
don't because it takes away the natural
oil of your hair and it makes it worse
even losing hair faster because of the
harsh ingredients in certain shampoo so
the question is is it true
well I personally believe yes and no it
depends on the shampoo that you use
certain shampoos I mean most shampoos
actually are terrible for you it strips
the skin of essential oils which is the
secret to a soft shiny healthy looking
Mane and yes it is then a money making
scheme because it puts you in this cycle
where you over clean your hair it strips
all the oil and then your body goes in
overdrive to produce more oil again and
this circle just repeats itself over and
over again now this is all because of
the harsh ingredients and the sulfates
in shampoo
a good example is head and shoulders I
used to use it a lot you know because of
dandruff but then you start to rely on
these products and you have to use it
over and over again so they make more
money and you just use it and you go in
that kind of rat race you know you kind
of run run run the same thing happens
over and over again now here's the key
what you need to do is to try and find
out how to treat your hair and your
scalp
everyone every person you are unique
every person is different for example I
tried it out I stopped washing my hair I
just rinsed it off with water
and I did that for a few weeks
but the problem with me is that I have
extremely Sensitive Scalp and I started
to get dandruff I just rinsed my hair
with water and hope that it will go away
but he didn't so I am not a guy that can
not wash his hair even if I don't use
any hair products you know I still get
dandruff and it doesn't really work for
me so what I realized is I'm a guy well
I need to use hair products because my
hair is thin and kind of dead so I need
to style it to look better but then I
cannot just try to rinse my hair with
water to try and clean it because it's
not going to clean all that hair
products so I need something to clean it
something like shampoo but just
something that that's not gonna destroy
my hair my scalp now if you don't use
any hair products you can go for it why
not try it out stop washing your hair
just wash it out every two to three days
now let's say every two days is better
just with water and see if it works but
not cold water
warm water because cold water won't work
so I went on this journey where I needed
something to clean my hair but I don't
want to use shampoo with bad ingredients
in it
so geology my favorite skincare brand
for men they just brought out something
that's really cool it's called a co-wash
it is not a shampoo not a conditioner
not a two in one it has no sulfates and
no harsh chemicals but it can definitely
clean your hair it doesn't strip your
hair of natural oils it nourishes the
scalp with dermatologist proven
ingredients and it is great for all hair
types not just mine now they have two
types let me give you a close-up a
cooling co-wash for normal to oily skin
which basically contains vitamin B5 tea
tree oil aloe vera Menthol and squalen
the other one is called smoothing
co-wash which is for normal to dry skin
and it has vitamin B5 avocado coconut
oil and squalen so this is basically
just a natural formulated foam cleanser
I would say and I like it it's good for
my hair and the cool thing is that I can
use this for my beard as well which is
pretty cool I wanted to make this video
for you guys to show you a product
that's actually really good and that
works this is not just something that
cleans your hair it is a treatment so it
treats your scalp the reason why this is
so good for your scalp is because it
activates blood flow and improves hair
growth so you don't need to worry about
losing your hair unnaturally because of
shampoo but with that being said you
need to know the truth that some of us
men will still go bold not because of
Any products or shampoo or anything but
just because of our genes
because of dehydro testerone the way our
bodies respond to our testosterone
according to healthline.com by age 35
approximately 66 percent of men will
have experienced some degree of hair
loss now you guys who's been here on my
channel from the start you know that I'm
part of that 66 yes I'm slowly losing my
hair but I'm doing everything I can to
prevent it or at least just to slow it
down and so the co-wash just came out at
the right time because I was actually
looking for something new and I've been
trying it out it works and it's
basically just an anti shampoo and a
really good hair treatment so check out
the video description you'll find your
discount code if you want to try it out
and hey if you want to know what makes
you lose your hair and what things you
can do to prevent it normal everyday
things check out this video here and
I'll see you there and before you go
always remember this life is short so
don't waste your
cheers guys